Nói 2 ngày 25, 2 năm, 2 ngày 29, tôi lần trải trên vụ thứ ba, anh hàng ngọt sân, tôi chung sân, xã bảo ái,
nghe thế tiến và trạm lớn trên vụ. Dứ cầm video trọng lành, chỉ kiết cầm thơ chiến đàn pin,
anh sân một mình trải thuyền tới hệ chương, các lần trải của anh khoảng 40,000.
Hí tới nơi, anh khô khỏi bằng hoàng khi giữa mặt hổ mình mong sâu lại, người nội, người chim, áo phao và đùa đặt chương lẫn và nhau.
Sau khi kí cứ được sống người đặc trời vừa giữa mặt hổ mình mong, gió thuyền nhỏ không thể chờ thiên người,
anh sân một phải đưa những người đất cứu được vào bờ, đồng thời điên hệ chính quyền địa phương,
nhưng người báo công an sá trước khi quay lại hủ tế thuộc tình kiếm,
đưa vệ lâu lực tế thuộc tình kiếm bất thành, anh sân đánh khoinh của việc trường bằng cách thả nhau để lực lượng cứu hổ sốc định vị chi.
Anh sân chia sẻ vì mươi sinh giữa lòng vụ thức bản nhớ năm nay tính và trạm là tôi biết có tổ gặp nạn.
Không ý nhiều, tôi lâu ra thuyền của mình để đến chỗ tổ bị nạn,
nhiều quay nước, quay gió và tục tưởng lụng lệnh tổ định hướng được trong linh tối phán đoán vị chi tổ chiến.
Hí tơi nơi, tôi thấy chiến tạo trở đã đả lùi ra xa khoảng năm nay mết, trên mặt nước, người nội, người chiến.
Một số người đã bám được vào tổ đã, một số thiệu ông trên nhỏ đang cố gắng kêu cử,
bằng vấy giữa sống nước lạnh.
Lúc đấy, tôi chỉ nghĩ làm sao cứu được nhiều người nhất có thể,
tinh yên, tạo của tôi nhỏ qua, chỉ trở được sống người, tinh đữa là lật.
Chào sút đến đó và ngày hôm sau, anh sân vẫn tiếp tục khối trở các lực lượng tình kiếm người mất tích.
Chính nhờ có sự khối trở tích cửa của những người như anh sân đã giúp các lực lượng trức nạn sớm
tìm thấy thi tế của sấu nạn nhân sấu xấu trong vụ tên nạn.
Cô chuyện về hành động giúp cảm kíu người của anh hàng ngọt sơ nạn toàn như một ánh lượng áp sữa những,
đau thương trong vụ tên nạn sấu thông đường thuyền nghiên trọng sửa tại vùng hủ thức bà thuộc việc bản sả bỏ ái, tình lâu kai.